let's talk about Venezuela now for
context I've done stories in the past
about Venezuela and very often there's a
contingent on the left that defends the
Venezuelan authoritarian dictatorship
and there's this sort of triad there's
an overlap there's a contingent of the
American left that likes to defend
Russia never exactly clear why defend
Venezuela and criticize Israel in a way
that sort of goes beyond reasonable
policy criticisms into a more unhinged
and apoplectic apologia for lack of a
better term and very often they
criticize the Venezuelan opposition as
being terrorists or puppets of the
American CIA they sort of portray the
Bolivarian regime formerly led by Hugo
Chavez now by President Nicolas Maduro
as just a great thing for the people and
meanwhile we've seen incredible
reporting over the last week not that
much in the American media I would say
but I've been watching a lot of South
American coverage of what's going on in
Venezuela from outside of Venezuela so
for example a really good piece on
Sunday night there's an Argentinian
journalist Claudette lanata
who does a show every Sunday night he
was in in Venezuela he was actually
deported immediately upon arrival ended
up having to fly to Panama Houston and
ultimately to get back to Argentina on a
United Airlines flight I mean just crazy
what's been going on there and they are
very clearly showing us that 90 year-old
women standing in the heat in line for
hours waiting for a single bag of rice
there's barely any toilet paper in the
country a loaf of bread if it's even
available costs what you might earn in a
in a day if not several days on the
average salary there and it is total and
utter chaos right now and it's only
escalated okay the Venezuelan
authorities seized two opposition
leaders ok Leopoldo Lopez and Antonio
Ledezma both of whom were under house
arrest for prior convictions those prior
convictions are a story
in and of themselves of course their
house arrest had been revoked because
authorities said they're planning to
flee now if you don't understand what's
going on in Venezuela in terms of the
lack of press freedom the lack of
judicial independence the lack of law
enforcement independence you might hear
all listen
they broke the conditions they were
planning to flee so they were arrested
that's the sickness of it all people
hear about this report about these two
opposition leaders being or being
arrested and they think well listen they
were legitimately convicted by an
independent judicial system carried out
but the arrests were carried out by an
independent law enforcement system and
it's all on the up-and-up
far from it and all of this is related
to president Nicolas Maduro calling for
elections this past Sunday the elections
were boycotted by the opposition
almost everyone elected to the
legislative body are supporters of
Maduro which I'm sure comes as a huge
surprise and meanwhile the United States
has placed new sanctions specifically on
the Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro
putting sanctions in to freeze his
assets at least the ones that are
subject to American jurisdiction u.s.
citizens are also barred from dealing
with Nicolas Maduro according to the
Treasury Department
now some on the Left will hear about
what's going on in Venezuela and I'm
already seeing them online and they will
say Oh David the CIA and US agencies
have a long history of messing up Latin
American countries Maduro is still
better than whatever the neoliberal
American community would install in
Venezuela let's hold on a second right
these are separate issues I know about
the u.s. messin messing up Latin
American countries and their priorities
being at odds with those of the people
of many Latin American countries I was
born in Argentina I follow South
American politics very very closely so
that's fine that's a perfectly
reasonable in fact-based position to
take that does not get us to Maduro as a
savior and the opposition are terrorists
installed by the American CIA we've seen
allegations that the opposition in
Venezuela is ringers or that the
opposition is faking
the bad act by the government to make
them look bad right a sort of false flag
or something all of those arguments
could have anecdotal grains of truth but
the narrative constructed from it is
completely bogus and another one is it's
astroturf the protest the opposition
protests are astroturf paid for by the
United States there is really good
reporting from other countries about
what's going on in Venezuela and I would
implore you a lot of these are subtitled
when you look at them on YouTube for
people who don't understand Spanish
check out what's happening on the ground
there and and find out for yourself you
know whether or not you can point to one
protest in Venezuela that was u.s.
sponsored whatever that means and it's
very hard to prove a negative as we know
there are endless protests and
opposition activism in Venezuela that
have no connection whatsoever to
American money so I'm really concerned
about what's going on there from a
humanitarian perspective but I'm also
really concerned about this string on
the American left and this is the same
people that are denying any Trump Russia
collusion despite the fact that we now
have Trump lying about Trump jr.
statement and drafting it and in-person
intent to collude via a meeting with a
Russian lawyer I mean it's endless right
the same contingent that is pretending
that there's nothing to see there is
often the same contingent that is
defending Venezuela as some amazing
example of democratic socialism and the
truth is that it is far from it it is a
right-wing authoritarian regime send me
your thoughts I know many of you will
disagree many will say David's a shill
for who I don't know because I don't
even know what it is that the CIA has
said about this I frankly don't care
what I care about is what is actually
happening in Venezuela I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show I'm thrilled to tell you
that today's episode of the show is made
possible in part by taga dab the hosting
specialists offering dedicated virtual
private and cloud server solutions as
well as custom server solutions for
whatever business or project
have taga dabs web hosting services
support a very wide range of customers
and businesses that includes bloggers
tech startups financial traders gamers
web developers it's a very very long
list they've got a user-friendly
interface they have absolutely fantastic
technical support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
you can get a 20 British Pound discount
off of a cloud server account with taga
dab but you've got to know how to access
that and the way you access it is by
going to sign up CagA DAB comm /td PS
and using the coupon code TDPS
20 this is a great way to get great
hosting for your project business or
service and support the David Pakman
show and support our advertisers that
sign up tag adapt calm slashed edps
that's ta ga da B and then the discount
code is T DPS 20